nos bons soirs docteur tremblay bonsoir
de sirois alors on voit depuis plusieurs
jours en europe dans les pays que j'ai
nommé il ya vraiment là la courbe est
impressionnante vers le haut est ce que
vous craignez pas ce que les vagues ont
toujours commencé
en europe et sont arrivés ici ce que
vous craignez que ça arrive ou faut
faire attention compte tenu de nos taux
de vaccination ben je crois qu'il faut
faire attention parce que à date jusqu'à
présent ce qui s'est passé en europe au
toujours prédit ce que nous on ne subit
quelques semaines après par soi c'est un
mois de décalage
c'est certain qu'une différence et la
différence des majeures en termes de
taux de vaccination où on voit que les
pays même en europe qui ont un taux de
vaccination plus élevé voit moins de
notre passion moins important du nombre
de communes voit qu'avec une
augmentation du nombre de cas alors
c'est vraiment reliés à la vaccination
ce sont des épidémies de nos bacs signer
essentiellement et on sait qu'une
certaine proportion des gens vaccinés
peuvent avoir la maladie mais dans la
majorité des cas elles ne font pas de
maladies curables donc oui il faut
suivre ça de près ici parce que ça
risque d'arriver que la transmission
communautaire se remettait à augmenter
d'autant plus qu'on relâche certaine
mesure la partir d'aujourd'hui bon on
rappelle aux gens que les
hospitalisations en ontario au québec
sont reste stable donc ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle pour l'instant
est ce que vous dites c'est une épidémie
de non vaccinés une pandémie non
vaccinés est ce qu'on est sûr et certain
avec études à la pluie que les vaccinés
drassm est moins la maladie cole et non
vaccinés on sait que les vacciner
peuvent transmettre la maladie certaines
études ont démontré que peu importe la
charge virale que la charge virale peut
être similaire chez une personne non
vaccinés que chez une personne vaccinée
soit simple raison que quand on attrape
la maladie si on est asymptomatique si
elle ne descend pas dans les voies
respiratoires
au niveau du nez c'est pas là que les
anticorps combat donc on peut avoir pas
mal de virus dans les voies
respiratoires supérieures puis la
transmettre aux autres donc on peut dire
que les vaccins je regardais mes
chiffres encore aujourd'hui vont
protéger de l'infection
symptomatique est sévère encore dans des
pourcentages très élevé lors on est dans
les 90 85 à 90% mais la transmission des
plus autour de l'ordre de 80% ou 75%
donc peut-être une belle gueule de
pourcin de gens qui peuvent l'approcher
même si son look si donc les vacciner
quand même répondre de moins la maladie
que les non vaccinés ça c'est dur en
faire comme falla en fait c'est que ya
moins de personnes vaccinées qui vont
attraper la maladie au départ donc en
soi c'est ce qui le fait donc il attrapa
ils vont pas la transmettre mais si ils
l'attrapent ils peuvent transmettre
aussi efficacement qu'une personne
vaccinée alors je pense que c'est cela
nuances qu'il faut faire c'est que même
si on est asymptomatique complet
transmettre la preuve les petits enfants
sont des vecteurs importants de la
maladie donc son pot symptomatique qui
n'ont pas de maladie sévère mais ils
transmettent ok mais vous me dire avant
vous dites quelqu'un qui est vacciné
n'attrapera pas la maladie donc il ne
peut pas la transmettre mais quelqu'un
qui est vacciné peut plus être en
contact avec la coved
vivre avec sans problème et ne pas être
malade oui je me suis probablement mal
exprimé les gens qui sont vaccinées
voulu protéger contre la maladie sévère
le décès les utilisations du à la coved
aura un ordre d'à peu près 90% mais il a
peu près ce qu'ils sont protégés contre
la maladie elle-même l'infection à peu
près de l'ordre de 70 à 80% donc parmi
les vaccinés il ya peut-être 20 à 30 %
des gens qui peuvent attraper le virus
mais ne pas devenir maman restez
asymptomatique et ces gens là peuvent
transmettre la maladie
ok donc toutes ces raisons là vous
continuent à militer selon vous pour
qu'on pousse la vaccination encore le
côlon on encourage les gens se faire
vacciner qu'on a qu'on arrête pas de se
faire vacciner
absolument parce qu'on voit que c'est là
qu'est ce qui va faire la grande
différence entre le fait ce qu'on va
avoir une cinquième bague comme en
europe non on a déjà une bonne longueur
d'avancé aux plusieurs pays d'europe
mais on a encore une proportion de la
population de nos macs ciné qui est
importante on parle de millions de
personnes donc toutes ces personnes ne
peuvent attraper la maladie y être à
risque dans leurs gilles le système de
santé donc on a tous hâte que les
autorisations pour les enfants d'être
dac signer arrive bientôt et on c'est
important de continuer à soutenir les
efforts pour que leur reste la
population se fasse vacciner et ne perde
pas son immunité donc la troisième dose
va devenir très important
dr tremblay merci beaucoup de nous avoir
parlé on va surveiller cette cinquième
vague européenne est ce qu'elle viendra
ou non dans quelle mesure ici merci
beaucoup nous n'avons pas utilisé